Hello, Austin ISTD family. This is Matia
Sigura, superintendent. I'm here to
provide a uh an update regarding our
turnaround plans uh that will be
submitted for approval and uh ultimately
approved on November 20th. Um we were
wanting to have a work session with our
board of trustees. Uh unfortunately,
just given kind of the balance of time
that we have to to manage, we weren't
able to do so. Um, but I think it's
really really important that we spend
time and we walk our community through
uh what these plans are, how we arrived
at the recommendation and what feedback
along the way we received uh that made
these plans stronger and uh those that
know me know that I'm committed to
engaging with community um and taking
community voice and incorporate it into
the work. I I strongly believe that if
we do that and do it consistently, we
will always have a better solution.
And so, as we talk about this work, it's
important to note that there are lots of
things um putting pressure um on Austin
ISD. And we're also trying to to do uh
work that moves our school school system
forward. And we talk about it a lot. You
talk about, you know, as a school
district, the fact that we want to have
strong neighborhood schools everywhere
in Austin ISD, so that families don't
feel as though they have to leave their
neighborhood uh to go um to a school
that is going to provide um for their
student um what they need to be
academically successful. And using that
as a guiding principle, uh we have to
acknowledge that, you know, right now
that's not happening. that we have um
schools and that have not been
historically supported in the way that
they needed to be in order to achieve
those outcomes. And so to to do this
work uh it it requires us being bold. It
requires us being thoughtful and also
acknowledging that to do it and it it
requires all of us doing it together.
meaning the entire school school system
116 schools 70,000 students and doing it
at a time when there are lots of
pressures within the school system you
know specifically Austin ISTD we can
certainly point to the TA agreed order
and the work that's been done uh there
um the everchanging accountability
system which we absolutely have to be
responsive to the fact that you know
declining enrollment over the last um
many years is something that we have to
uh you know work Peru and also
acknowledge that changes at the federal
level regarding immigration have made it
even harder.
And so, you know, all of that pressure
kind of coupled with the fact that, you
know, the rising cost of education um is
not being uh supported by the state by
way of meaningful investment the way
that we would hope. We certainly
acknowledge that there's been
investment, but given kind of where we
are and the pressures that we have, uh
we certainly believe that there um is
much more work to do to really get us to
where we need to be. And so, as part of
this work, uh we have to acknowledge
that um as a school district, we have to
submit uh turnaround plans. And a
turnaround plan is uh required by the
state of Texas or Texas agent agency.
And you can see here the code uh that um
is used to provide that direction. And
you'll often hear us talk about it as as
a tap, a tap turnaround plan. And
turnaround plans or taps are required by
the state of Texas whenever a school
reaches two unacceptable accountability
counts. And uh I want to be really
clear. An unacceptable accountability
count uh is a combination of different
things. It can be three D's uh in in
succession could equate to one
unacceptable accountability count. an F
certainly does. And as these accumulate
um over the years going back to 2018,
2019, uh whenever you have a school that
reaches two, you are required to develop
a turnaround plan. And the purpose of a
turnaround plan is to ensure that the
school district um has a a plan that is
responsive, that invests, and clearly
communicates to the agency how we are
going to break the accountability chain.
And that means getting a C or better.
And if the school district is unable to
do that, um, and the school reaches a
fifth unacceptable accountability
rating, the commissioner shall, and I
want to point out, shall, you can see it
here in bold and underlined, order the
school, uh, order the closure of the
school or install a board of managers.
This is really really important because
when we think about um you know AISD and
our ability to um ensure that our
students are educated in a way that
lines with our values a critical
component of that and I would say the
most important point part of that is
ensuring that our board of trustees
provide that direction uh for the school
district. And so it's really really
important that we are responsive that we
um acknowledge that there's a tremendous
amount of work to be done uh in many of
these schools. We take full ownership of
that uh and also recognize that these
have built up over time. You know, these
are these are years of um kind of uh
challenges that that we have to
acknowledge. Um but we're committed to
doing the work. And what has made this
uh year very challenging for us as a
school system is that the 2023
accountability uh ratings uh were
released in the fall I mean sorry in the
spring of 2025. So just about you know
six months ago and then here in August
24 and 25 were released. So, so really
in a short period of time about four or
five months uh three years of
accountability ratings uh were released
by the agency and you can imagine how
that complicates our ability to develop
these turnaround plans and ensure that
they're completed with fidelity uh in a
way that aligns with who we are because
ultimately we will break these
accountability chains. I'm very
confident of it. we have uh the ability
to do so and um but it's important that
the compression of time has made it
challenging uh and certainly has created
confusion in the community and I just
wanted to acknowledge that
[clears throat] as we think through uh
the different strategies that are
available to the school to different
schools uh or to school districts there
are really six uh that are outlined by
the Texas education agency and I'm
briefly going to highlight what they are
uh the first one is intensive curriculum
and instruction improvement uh it's
usually called school improvement. We
have restart district managed. Uh this
would be similar to what uh you're we're
seeing right now as a community at Dolby
Burn and Web. Uh we have a restart
partner managed. This is where an 1882
partner comes in uh and restarts the
entire school. In this instance, all
staff, administrative staff um are
employees of the partner, not of the
school district. So, so just to be
really clear, it's, you know, in a
district restart, it's all of our staff,
AISD employees. If it's a district
partner restart, it's our partners'
employees. We also have closure and
reassignment. Uh, this is uh where the
students are reassigned um from one
campus to another. Uh the idea here is
um the school that they're being
reassigned to uh is is higher performing
and the work that they've been doing
there uh will allow um those students to
benefit and with additional supports
they'll be able to to meet um kind of
the expectations uh of the school
district and and beyond grade level and
ultimately break the accountability
chain. We also have a new school uh
district managed. This is when a school
uh transforms. Uh it really goes through
a closure and then it kind of restarts
and ends up being um a different school.
This could be a school that has a
different um kind of student population,
a different program. It needs to be
substantially different. Uh but you can
imagine the amount of time that's
required to develop and implement a new
school model. Uh and the same is also
true for a new school partner managed.
So these are the six options that school
districts uh have available to them. I
want to be really really clear that many
of these are available um to uh two UA
or two schools that have two
unacceptable accountability ratings. But
as you progress through the
unaccountability, the accountability
chain and get to three UAS, um some of
these fall off because it's clear that
you don't have the time in order to
build out um you know, the plan in order
to to ensure that the students
ultimately um reach academic success.
And so, uh a lot of times I'm asking the
community, you know, how come this this
three UA campus can't get um approved to
do a, you know, campus improvement plan?
And the reality of it all is, you know,
the the work um has to match the urgency
in the turnaround plan um regarding the
number of unacceptable accountability
ratings. So if you have three UAS, you
know, the restart, partner managed,
closure, reassign, and district managed
uh restart are really available to you.
Um and then if you are a 2UA, you have
kind of the complement or the the all
six available. Uh when we begin to
evaluate these, we take a lot of things
into consideration, but I also want our
community to know that we're also
getting feedback from region 13 uh our
partner as well as Texas Education
Agency just to ensure that we are on the
right track as we explore different
strategies for for all of our campuses.
And when we do this work, we um have to
be uh aligned with just who we are. And
so we have to be thinking about um you
know, how do we incorporate community
feedback? you know, how do we limit
disruption uh of students moving if
they're going to be reassigned? Uh we
have to acknowledge that, you know,
making a a a move uh requires us to
analyze the capacity of the school, the
funds required to um add capacity if
that's the case. And then ultimately we
have to ensure that we have the funds uh
in order to um pay for the resources uh
in order to to break the accountability
chain. And we'll talk about what some of
those additional resources are here in a
moment. Uh but it's really important
that we develop a plan that we know will
be accepted by the agency and two we
know that we can execute uh with
fidelity. And I am someone that is um
very clear about the expectations and
our ability to execute these plans. Um
which is why this balance uh makes this
iterative process sometimes uh
challenging because that we're always
wanting to test, you know, what have we
heard from our community? What do we
know will be accepted? And then as a
school district, what do we know we can
actually accomplish? Other
considerations uh that we have to um be
be responsive to are just the academic
history of of the school um that we'll
be receiving students. Uh there are
guidelines um success criteria uh that
the agency has identified. uh these are
not statutes but they um do believe and
that you know if school if a student is
going to move to a new school that it
should be a a school in good standing an
AB or C rated school or have that
student should or have access to one and
so you'll see some of that come out in
the work as we go kind of campus by
campus. Uh the other thing is we always
want to um acknowledge that there aren't
um an infinite number of uh staff or
principles that will meet the criteria
in some of these plans. And and what I
mean by that is whenever you have a dis
a district managed restart, which is
also known as kind of an ACE model, we
have certain criteria that have to be
applied. Uh in some cases, it's number
of years of experience. Um, if it's an
educator, they have to have demonstrated
uh being highly effective, which is a
term the state uses, which which really
means that their performance is
correlated to student performance.
And also we uh or TIA designated or a
nally board certified teacher. And so in
Austin ISD, we have lots of incredible
educators doing incredible things. Many
of them have these designations. Uh but
what we're trying to avoid are, you
know, firstear teachers uh in these
schools that need more support uh or
teachers that might be successful
elsewhere in the school district, which
is why the intentionality around the
staffing plan is so important. Uh it's
also important to note that when it
comes to administrative staff, most
notably the principal, you know, that
principal or that leader um really
should uh demonstrate um kind of a
history of um breaking accountability
chains or going from an F to a C or a D
to a B. And uh there's nuance in that.
There there are ways that that can be
achieved. Um, but when we talk about
restarts that and when it comes to AIC's
ability to implement, we need to make
sure we have those staff available uh to
do so. And so that's also a
consideration uh as part of this work.
When we think about uh where we are as a
school district and the number of
turnaround plans that we have to be
responsive
uh around um I wanted to organize it in
a way that was really really clear. So
um you know this plan that we have been
working with uh working through over the
last many months includes lots of things
right there's alignment of feeder
patterns there's uh you know
programmatic moves to ensure this the
focus of the program is with the
students who uh kind of were the
foundation uh and also balance
enrollment for consolidations
uh the be responsive to the turnaround
plans uh and and also address transfer
challenges and transfer policy
challenges that we've had in in the
past. And so this is a a component of
that larger body of work. Um but I will
say that because we're doing it all of
it together um or it's all part of one
plan uh there are opportunities that
that we've been able to explore that
wouldn't otherwise um have we we
wouldn't have otherwise been able to do.
And so for our closure and reassign um
uh strategies tied to TAPS, you can see
here those are all three UA campuses. uh
Bington, Betich, Dawson, Oak Springs,
Martin, Wyn, and Wood. Uh when it comes
to restarts, and we're again we're going
to get into each of these campuses,
there are five of them, uh at Linder,
Sanchez, Spaz, Piccant Springs, and
Waldridge. And then when it comes to
school improvement, these are those
schools that um have two UAS
uh and um are really on the right path,
and just need some additional support.
And um you know, we're confident that
with the trajectory we have, they'll be
able to to meet that um the expectation
of breaking the accountability chain. Um
and I do want to apologize that three
right there should be a two uh on the
slide. We'll get that corrected.
So, as a school district, I want to be
really clear that we uh acknowledge that
there are lots of supports that we are
going to um provide to all of our
schools. um you've seen some of them
uploaded onto our our backup documents.
I do want to um kind of reinforce a
couple of them because it can feel
repetitive if I kind of state these over
and over and over again. So, I just
wanted to kind of pull them out to the
to the beginning of this presentation
and just kind of share this is what
we're doing to all just in support of
all these schools. So, provide
additional uh transition support for
students receiving special education
services. Uh we've we've done a lot of
work with um Dr. Cherry Lee, assistant
superintendent of special education,
just be really intentional to ensure
that the transition is is supported uh
and the students uh needs are being met.
Uh parent engagement opportunities
focused on student academic success,
enrollment, and transition planning. you
know, in Austin ISD, we um believe that
this is a partnership um with our
families, but we also know that not all
families have uh kind of the t the same
amount of time or able to access um you
know, our schools to um get what they
need to ensure that they understand
where their student is in their academic
uh journey. And so these plans uh which
are um much more uh um kind of involved
and detailed than what we're actually
going to submit to the document to the
agency because the agency has a template
uh include like what will that look like
on a campus? Um how we will we use
parent support specialists uh to create
those connections. What training do our
parent support specialists need to have?
what's the expectation of teachers and
how many times should they uh engage and
interact with uh parents at these
schools versus other schools. So, we're
being very intentional about setting
those expectations and ensuring that we
deliver.
Uh we um also are going to be very um
thoughtful about the training um with
our staff uh at these campuses. Um
certainly ensuring that we have high
quality instructional material but also
um as we continue to build that muscle
in the system uh just ensuring fidelity
and and we have done a lot of work over
the last year. But when we think about
kind of where that alignment needs to
occur um just being very supportive
providing additional um opportunities
for professional development. Then also
seeing, you know, in these schools, are
there other um individuals who are part
of the academic um kind of network of
support but maybe aren't traditionally
in the professional development
experience? Uh and so we're making those
adjustments and you'll see that'll be
throughout all of these taps as well. Uh
summer school and summer learning
opportunities or other enrichment
opportunities, it's something that we
believed in. I would we believe in in
years past. it hasn't been coordinated
in a way that is um really met my
expectation. Uh as you move forward, uh
you're going to be able to see in the
summertime, you know, we're going to
have these programs at these schools. Uh
we are going to phone bank, make calls
to these students, invite them in. Uh
and this is where the funding begins to
to really um be a component of the work.
you know, in years past, we've been able
to rely on different resources
uh and and those have just unfortunately
dried up. So, we have to be really
intentional about where we provide uh
these supports, how we do it, and ensure
that we're making the phone calls like
we're we're engaging with our families
uh to take um take every opportunity to
to be successful as they start the next
school year.
We also um for some of these transition
plans that are tied to taps be really
thoughtful about any um kind of uh any
opportunity to um address either chronic
absenteeism or just increase the average
daily attendance. We know that when
students are in school uh more um we see
great things and uh we as a school
district we've done a lot of work around
reducing chronic absenteeism. But when
it comes to these specific schools, what
are we doing? What are our plans? how is
the principal and our team here at
central office going to align and once
that alignment occurs I'm going to
develop KPIs to track each of these
plans. So, one of the reasons that it's
important to talk about these because a
lot of the details um that I think
sensor community are are looking for and
looking through are are really really at
the campus level. And so what we do is
provide the framework, provide the
resources, and then we work with the
principal to detail these out. And
again, many of these things are uh more
than what the agency actually requires
or or needs of our plans, but we are
committed to uh ensuring that um that's
all included. And then lastly, just
being really intentional about staffing.
Uh, you know, I think this is a missed
opportunity for the district uh in some
cases for years when you really think
about, you know, which educators have um
built that familiarity on our campuses,
have the relationships, have
demonstrated um the ability to to grow
students over the course of the year.
Are we putting them um in a space where
we know our students are going to
benefit most? uh or are we kind of
building just a master schedule the way
that we have in the past. So this is one
of those things where you know being
really intentional about how we support
our students u going down to the tools
that we have and one of those is the
master schedule. So um all of that is
incorporated in all of these plans.
Uh as I dive deeper into um some of the
uh the turnaround plans, I just want to
be really clear that everything we
talked before will apply to all of
these. Um but now we're going to get
into some of the kind of decision-
making um kind of logic behind um some
of the um behind each of the turnaround
plans. And so we'll start first with
closure and reassignments.
So we're going to start first with
Bington. Uh Bington is a um smaller um
elementary school about 300 students. Uh
you can see here the ratings. Uh this is
the first time that you'll see ratings
and uh on our slides and I want to be
really clear that you know these
accountability chains uh and
unaccessible accountability counts go
back to the 1819 school year. Uh so
that's before you know many of us uh our
board I mean these go back a ways and so
you know I want to just kind of
reinforce that we have been working very
very hard and our system is responding
but some of the the um unaccountab
unacceptable accountability counts that
that we are having to be responsive to
um are just are just back at a time when
when we were a different organization.
Uh but we take full ownership. uh we we
are going to ensure that our students
are successful. Uh but I just wanted to
provide that data point. Uh also you'll
see here in 2020 and 2021 uh uh no
rating uh that's because of the
pandemic. Uh the Texasation agency did
not release um ratings and in one year
we actually didn't even take the star.
And then in 2022 uh rating uh scores
were released but not ratings. And again
this is kind of part of the transition
out of the um the pandemic. So when you
look at Bington Elementary School, uh
given the size and and kind of the
proximity to um other schools, this is
one where we felt strongly that the
reassignment
uh and closure option would be um would
be best. Uh you do have a clo a school
that's very very close uh in Goro
Thompson and then Woolridge which is not
too far away. And when you think about
boundaries and the ability for each
school to receive those students uh and
the um kind of balance of the student
population uh and and profile uh this is
one that became um you know a good
recommendation for a closure and
reassignment.
Some of the things that we also consider
just when you break it down is that the
majority of the students uh will go to
um Goro Thompson uh which is B-rated. uh
the uh remaining students will go to uh
Waldridge about 25%. Uh but the tap the
turnaround plan at Bington will be
assigned to Guo Thompson. I also might
really want to be really really clear uh
Wooldridge is also being restarted. Uh
so there may be a question well Matias
you know how why would you send students
to a school that also has these ratings?
I I want to be just crystal clear. Well,
we acknowledge that and we are going to
restart that campus and we'll talk about
that here in a little bit. Um, we are
budgeting about a million dollars uh for
each of the uh restarts uh sorry each of
the uh the taps. Um this one
specifically is about a million dollars.
Uh which includes staffing, stipens, uh
additional um instructional coaches,
content interventionists and counselors.
uh we um provided some ratios uh in
previous documents that that we are
going to incorporate. I want to also be
very intentional here that every school
has different needs when it comes to
staffing. And so what we do here is we
allocate funds in a budget, but we don't
necessarily say this is how we intend to
use it at this point. The reason being
in this case is is a really good case is
go Thompson um has had stability.
they've obviously had um high outcomes
for a period of time. Um I would we want
to make sure that we are responsive to
what Grow Thompson needs to support all
of our students. Uh and in that way it
may not be instructional coach. Maybe
it's a a different um kind of group of
staff. We really want to incorporate
that. And so at this level with how
we're building these taps, it's
important that we leave flexibility so
that when we um work into the next
school year, we can make the adjustments
as we need to. And uh also in each of
these we incorporate um funds for family
engagement. Again, it's really really
important that we create that connection
with community. Uh and on the bottom
here you can see some of the other um
components of the receiving schools uh
communities and schools at Waldridge and
then prime time after school programming
at Grow Thompson. Now as we move forward
we'll continue to add um you know
there's going to be opportunities for
additional programming. Uh a lot of that
um is it's committed to we have the
funds for but that work continues as
these details um get built out over the
remainder of the spring semester. Uh so
this is Goro Thompson again 75% assigned
um to uh this Bington 75% to Goro
Thompson and 25% to Waldridge. The one
thing also that comes into consideration
is the fact that Waldridge is going to
be a modernized school by way of the
2022 bond program. Uh and so anytime
that that you can provide the supports,
ensure the student is moving to um a
newer building, uh it it's going to be
um something that's going to uh be
viewed positively um by us um given the
complexities of of what we we need to
consider. The other thing I would say is
um a restart kind of at Bington uh
wasn't something that um we felt uh
would be the best option here mainly
because the surplus of seats that we
have in this area of town. Um you know
that restart and this is where it kind
of comes back to other elements of the
comprehensive plan. You know doing
restarts, doing tabs, aligning feeder
patterns and also reducing the number of
seats in a school in the school system
um are all part of our our overarching
goals. And this is one of the instances
where we can reduce the number of seats,
put students um in in newer buildings at
the same time um ensure that all of our
students get what they need to be
successful um with the majority going to
grow Thompson uh which is where the tap
will go. So moving on to uh Betachch
Middle School. Uh Betachch Middle School
uh in South Austin. Uh this is an area
where uh we have a surplus of middle
school seats. um the enrollment at 608
and you can see here the three years
that contributed to the um the three UA
so 23 24 and 25 it's also important to
note that you know these schools have
been doing such hard work uh they've
been progressing and working and um they
are so very close to pausing the
accountability chain which occurs if you
get a D or even breaking when you get a
C and we acknowledge that um we we
certainly see the work we spend time um
understanding and and recognizing that
um with more time um these could be
broken um in a different way. But we
also have to acknowledge that there are
a surplus of seats here in in South
Austin. Uh and the the reality that you
know three years into a fivey year
accountability chain doesn't give us a
lot of um opportunity to um address this
without this type of uh kind of um
urgency. And so here you can see uh u
three different colors. The the green on
the top um those students will uh move
to Mendes uh which is a currently a
rated as a B school. Uh the majority of
the students uh will go to Cington to
the west and then the students to the
south will go to Pettas u which we'll
talk about here in a moment. One of the
things that's that's unique about
Betachch is that it's surrounded by
middle schools. uh you know, Mendes and
Parees are both kind of on the um the
edge of the of AISD. And so moving the
student population um from that location
inward uh into the school system or into
the tenants boundary of the school
district is harder because you have
fewer schools that can help um
distribute the student population. And
so in this case, uh Covington will be
receiving the the turnaround plan. Uh
and um the one thing we also want to
reinforce as we've committed in our
documents and as we've committed in our
communication with community is the
intention here is to restart and
reimagine betach uh and um and and work
with community to bring a program online
uh that kind of meets the needs of the
school district but also meets the needs
of our community and we're committed to
doing that work. um it's an expectation
of our board. Uh and so um just wanted
to make that clear before I I leave this
kind of part of the the presentation.
When you see here the receiving school
um which is a little more of a focus,
you can see the breakdown. 58% going to
Cington, 13% going to Mendes and then
Petta's 23%. Uh you'll see here we have
the um allocation of of the funds. Uh
Cington Middle School um being a B uh in
23 and then the dip in 24 and then back
to a high C or higher C in 25. Uh based
on what uh we've seen at Cington and the
great work um by Cedric, uh it's we feel
very strongly that um they will continue
to to grow. Um, and it's really
important at this point that we plan
together uh to receive those students.
Uh, Mendes, uh, middle school, uh,
smaller student population. Uh, this is
a school that is currently run by Third
Future, a 192 partner that's been in
place to break the accountability chain
from years back. Uh, as part of the
comprehensive plan at Mendes, um, you
know, it will come back to Austin ISD.
That that's that's how this works. Uh
but we have to think through kind of
into in this interim phase um how we're
going to provide um options and access
for those students who um are going to
be assigned to Mendes. Um but again
they'll have other options within Austin
ISD. And the Petta Middle School uh has
been um showing growth. Uh we have a new
principal this year. I fully expect um
uh the team and the work that I've seen
um to contribute to breaking the to
moving to a pause if not breaking the
accountability chain. Uh so um feel very
strongly that this plan um works well
for South Austin. Uh and again this is
one of those areas where we just have a
surplus of middle school seats and when
you think about all the different
pressures um this solution is one that
uh we felt uh would be successful.
Couple things I want to point out here
is um we uh last year launched a
lighthouse program uh and it's been very
successful. It's really helped
contribute to the early literacy and
early numeracy um kind of uh growth that
we've seen which has been uh really
encouraging and in fact very uh very
promising. And so what we've decided to
do is expand that. And so what a
lighthouse program does is identifies um
a specific school and this is the first
time we're doing middle schools. Last
year was only elementary. and we um
create kind of a an observation loop uh
where other middle school principles
come and observe with the principal at
the lighthouse school and those are the
lab schools or learning labs. We learn
together, we share together and then
that goes back into the campuses and um
through support we end up all
collectively becoming um stronger. One
of the things that's a a big focus area
of ours is ensuring that our principles
are the instructional leaders on their
campus. Uh in years past, we provide
professional development to all of our
teachers and uh and staff and they would
go back into the schools, but it wasn't
always easy for our principles to
understand, you know, how are they
applying what they learned? um are they
um in a position to provide um you know
the the the best experience for our
students to ensure academic growth. But
now because we've switched how we do it
um our principles can see and provide
real-time coaching um can work with uh
their executive directors or other
principles to kind of share lessons
learned and improve. It really becomes a
network of learning and support. uh but
the leader of the school um ends up
being the kind of academic leader which
has not always been the case in Austin
ISD. Um so I'm really encouraged by what
we've seen uh and very um supportive of
us continuing the work and I feel
strongly that this will be successful uh
in this configuration for the turnaround
plan for Betachch
uh Dawson Elementary School uh student
enrollment. Um so it's a smaller
elementary school at 158. Uh you can see
here that um the last couple years um 23
through 25 um were all high were all um
FS uh 54 59 and 58. Uh I want to
acknowledge that this is another one of
those schools that we know been working
really hard um and and very close to
getting that pause but given the urgency
around the three UAS and the size of the
school a consolidation uh and a
reassignment um was the best solution to
break the accountability chain. And this
is the first time where uh something
comes up that I want to share with our
community and that is the way that um
the summit of assessment or star uh is
is administered and then how the
calculation works when you have really
really small schools um you know a few
students could move the accountability
rating uh pretty significantly. Uh we've
seen examples where one family um who
had been at the school the entire year
and then moved out uh for extenduating
circumstances uh kind of changed the
school's letter grade by two ratings. Uh
that is how sensitive uh this summit of
assessment can be when you have that few
students. Um and so you think about it
you know for elementary school the
testing grades are three, four and five.
So 158 students uh between preK uh four
and fifth grade, you have very few
students in each of those grade levels.
Um and then when you get to below 20 and
the 15s uh and you have two or three
that um just do not um are not able to
take the SAR assessment uh for whatever
reason, it can it can really change um
your ratings. And so that's just
something else I think it's it's
important we talk about. It certainly
isn't a driving factor, but the larger
that your student population gets um the
less sensitive um we are to having those
little disruptions change um the the
accountability rating. And so uh in this
instance um Galindo Elementary School is
going to be the receiving school uh for
Dawson. You can see here that this is a
great opportunity for us to have a whole
school um combined. Um anytime we can
keep community together, we we want to
do it. Uh we'll have lower teaching
ratios, student teacher ratios in K4,
one through 20. Uh and uh that'll
certainly be the case at Galindo. Um the
ratings for Galindo, you can see here um
have been uh relatively strong. 22 AB,
23 AB. Uh and again 23 of B is after the
accountability rating changed. Uh there
was a dip in 24. Uh we certainly um
understand why that occurred and then
we're building back up to a C and 77. So
they've broken the accountability chain.
Uh and there are great things happening
um at Galindo. And so um for us uh when
we think about you know the work here um
you know and the student populations we
we have to be really thoughtful of the
different services. Uh Galindo does have
a larger student population of uh
receiving special occasion services. Uh
they they have unique programming there.
Um they have a um a pantry for the
community and so there's a lot uh which
is why we need to be really intentional
about how the plans come together. Uh
they are very close um from a proximity
perspective. So, um, you know,
transportation,
uh, the the, um, kind of challenge of
getting families, uh, to the Galindo to
engage, um, isn't, uh, as big of a
concern as elsewhere, but we certainly
want to plan for it and do what we can
to support our families. Um the last
thing I'll say is that this is also um a
lighthouse um uh Glenda will also be
benefiting from the lighthouse program.
Um and uh and we'll have additional um
supports at the school including
including communities and schools and
prime time after school program. And
again, you know, we have dollars
allocated to expand uh as needed. So
next is Oak Springs Elementary School.
uh Oak Springs, uh a smaller elementary
school. And one of the things that I
think is important to talk about with
small elementary schools and is that um
any movement of students uh can really
impact accountability. And you'll hear
me say this a time or two throughout the
presentation.
And we know this because uh when you
have 250 215 students distributed
between you know prek4 kindergarten 1 2
3 4 and five and only with third fourth
and fifth grade testing uh for star. You
get into these grade levels that can
have you know 15 20 sometimes even like
12 students.
And when that happens so much is of the
rating of the school is dependent on so
few students. And we've seen in the past
where a family just moving late in the
year uh really changes the trajectory uh
of the ratings. And so, you know, we
have to be thinking about as we move
forward given the environment we're in
in the Texas education accountability
system, we really need to have student
populations uh that balance that out. uh
because as as hard as as our students as
our families are working and as hard as
our students are working um some slight
movement like that given the student
enrollment uh size can can really be
challenging to overcome. And so this is
an an example where um given proximity
to a higher performing school in
Blackshere and given the size of both
student populations we can actually
combine them to support the reassignment
of the program or reassignment of the
turnaround plan. So in this case 100% of
the students will be reassigned to
Blackshere. Uh currently Blackshere is a
C-rated campus. Uh if you look back um
there's been uh some really strong
history in 2022 was a 90 an A and 23 a D
24 a D and then moving to a C. So it's
moving certainly in the right direction.
And again you know that 22 23 year when
the star assessment changed you see that
huge drop. And again that's across the
board. We saw lots of B's go to Fs. In
this case you saw an A go to a D.
Um we are going to be allocating um an
investment of a million dollars. Uh the
um kind of type of of staff that'll be
uh you know um deployed at the campus is
really dependent on the needs of the the
of the community um based on the plan
itself. So we create some flexibility
there. Uh we are also looking to expand
communities and schools and prime time
after school program. And then uh what I
what's unique about Black Shear is the
fine arts program uh that exists. And so
we really want to think about how can we
lean into that and incorporate that into
the program so that um all the students
and new school population uh can can
take advantage of it uh and benefit. And
then lastly uh um Blackshere will
continue to be um part of the lighthouse
program. Again, this is a very strong um
kind of structure we put in place last
year and have it expanded it this year
and has really led to some of the the
success we've seen in early literacy. Um
so, continuing to do that work um
allocating the resources and also being
really thoughtful that the students near
Oak Springs need some support in
transportation uh and support in
ensuring that we engage with their
families. Uh it may seem close, but we
certainly recognize after having lots of
conversations with the community that
though it's close, it still may be a
challenge. And so we have to be really
intentional about engaging uh with those
families uh those Oakr families as they
transition into Black Share. The last
thing I'll say is uh this this plan is
in regards to the um the move for the
turnaround plan. Uh, and so effectively
what's what's happening here and and I'm
going to go back one slide is we're
combining two attendance boundaries. The
location of the school, you know, in the
future is is not part of this vote. Uh,
this is really about moving the student
body from Oak Springs to Black Shear,
have them come together and um ensuring
that we provide the supports
intentionally to to break the
accountability chain uh and that
students um get on grade level and get
what they need. uh the home long term
for you know whether it's Black Shear or
Oak Springs um is an ongoing
conversation. Uh we started out one way
in October 3rd and the 31st. There's
since been conversations with the
community. There's no decision, there's
no recommendation at this point. Uh it's
in fact a separate um thing entirely. Um
but we will continue to have
conversations with both communities
before we arrive at a a final um
solution for um the long-term home for
for these students in this community.
Uh Martin Middle School uh Martin Middle
School uh you can see here the the
ratings uh 57 46 and 56. Uh a smaller
middle school at 310 students. So very
very small um in these grades you know
all grades are testing. Uh it is um one
that um can be challenging because when
it comes to uh additional programming
that we know our students love and our
and we believe in uh the staffing
allocations become really difficult when
there's that few students. An example of
that would be um you know does choir
make or does uh you know other um
programs make because so few students
are are there. And so when we think
about Austin ISD and how important it is
that that we have these opportunities
for our students um and whether it's
athletics or you know visual performing
arts or um clubs or programs like all of
those things are um we can do but
they're hard when you don't have the
number of students to support the staff
allocation. And so that's just a a
constant um kind of tension in the in
the system. uh we have created floors so
that no school goes too low. Um but the
reality of it all is um you know to get
to a a a more balanced kind of number of
students uh would allow for for other
opportunities uh programmatically.
Uh the um the restart um solution I'm
sorry the closure solution is um for
Martin Middle School is to reassign the
students um to Keeling. Uh this is one
where it's not the majority uh as far as
over 50%. It is the majority of the
students um between uh Martin. Uh so
Keeling A rated 46% of the students will
be assigned there. Lively it's uh C
rating and then Marshall D with the with
the remainder at 28%. And so in this
instance, Kaling will receive the tap.
Um for Martin, you can see here the the
ratings. uh principal SS has been doing
great work uh over there um really kind
of balancing um the supports for our
students who are zoned uh and those that
are in the the magnet program. Uh it's
it's really important that we um
segregate all of our data and we
understand how each student is is is is
being supported within our school
system. Uh there are different programs
at Keeling that we're going to continue
to support as well as Marshall uh and
Lively. Um but wanted to be you know
really clear about kind of how this one
is different than um you know one of the
other schools that that we've looked at
where the majority of the students uh
are going. This is a a plurality. It's
the the and this is just really given
the complex complexity of the geography
of the city. Um wanting not to create
too much distance from where students
live and where the schools are. Um and
again it it is about providing that
access uh which we are committed to
doing. All right. So next, so next we
have Win Monasuri. Uh student enrollment
371.
Uh this is a a school that um as you can
see was certainly impacted by the um
assessment changing summit of assessment
changing in 2223 or STAR going from a 69
to a 45. Uh has since been making
tremendous progress um getting right to
where they're about to to get to a D and
and pause that accountability chain. Uh
haven't quite been able to get there
yet. And you know some of this is driven
by you know how monatory program you
know kind of fit or doesn't fit into the
um structure that is uh the state
accountability system. And so uh there's
been a lot of work um by the leadership
and by the staff to to move outcomes. Uh
you know it is a dual language campus
and there is a uh a lot of really great
things happening um at Win Monastery.
Um, in order to to to
address the turnaround plan, um, what
we're proposing is a reassignment of the
students to Andrews Elementary School,
which is currently uh, D-rated. Um, have
80% of the students go there and then
have uh, the remainder about 20% go to
Pan Springs. Uh, Pan Springs uh, is a
3UA campus, but we are restarting that,
and you'll you'll hear more about that
here in a little bit. Uh so we do feel
confident that even with the move uh it
won't be the same campus that those
students are going to. It'll be a
different campus um with with the
supports tied to the turnaround plan for
PCON Springs which is a restart. Uh
Andrews Elementary School, you can see
here the accountability chain um um from
22 23 74 and then it dropped as we've
talked about before and then it's it's
really um been able to move in the right
direction and there's been just great
things happening there. Uh and so we
feel strongly that um with the
additional supports with the work we've
been doing over the last two years uh
that Andrews is on its way to to
breaking the accountability chain uh
with the C or better. And so, uh, there
are some things that we have to
consider, um, not just the the
allocation of funds, uh, for staffing,
um, and for the modified teacher ratio,
student teacher ratios, but also for
family engagement, but also expansion of
programs, uh, with communities and
schools, uh, and the Andy Rodic
Foundation, which is currently at Panon
Springs, uh, and then the prime time
program at Andrews. So, uh, the other
thing that I I think is worth pointing
out and I actually had it listed here on
the first slide is that the monastery
program um at when is going to relocate
to Riley Elementary School. Um, and
Riley Elementary School currently has
um, uh, Mandarin and dual language and
those will be locating those programs
will be relocating uh, to to Wooten. And
so the uh, Raleigh Elementary School
will will convert into a neighborhood
school. Um but we're going to include a
strand um K through five for Monasuri
and we think in this way we'll be able
to continue to provide this offering to
our community which we know is is a very
desirable um and we certainly understand
the value and benefit of Monasuri. uh
but it also allows to create this
balance um in the student population and
in the program of the programs of the
entire school so that uh we're we're
successful um in the current environment
that we have to operate in. And so I
just wanted to call that out. It is
something that has changed um since we
started this plan. Uh and and I think
it's a clear indication of of us wanting
to be responsive to the community um and
and making changes where we can. Uh so
um do also feel strong that this this
plan um will be successful and um feel
confident that we'll break the
accountability chain uh for um when um
as we move forward uh um elementary
school uh so just east of of Mendes um
kind of on the east side kind of far
east of our attendance boundary the
school system uh would um the 23
received a 49 and 56 and 57. So, they've
been moving and working and really
trying to to get to that D to pause, but
they have accumulated three unacceptable
accounts, unacceptable rating accounts.
And uh with the enrollment um at uh
Woodane, um we've been able to make some
adjustments uh and and have the whole
student population go to Rodriguez. Uh
this is a different um solution than
what was originally shared on October
3rd and 31st. And this is a reflection
of just us um you know working with our
community um working with the agency um
working with our board uh to to really
try to think about you know if a student
is experienced uh has a certain type of
experience and we move them how can we
assure that um their academic journey is
going to be improved and they're going
to be supported in a way that will break
the accountability chain and um after
looking at everything and looking at the
space that we have Rodriguez uh um will
end up taking the whole entire um
student population at Wedane. Uh
previously it was just the majority. And
so uh the Rodriguez has has um kind of
um fluctuated a little bit over the over
the past. We've had stable leadership.
Um a lot of that was driven by changes
in the accountability system. Many of
you will hear me say time and time
again, you know, we had many schools in
2022 that were B's and then dropped to
Fs in 23. Uh this is an example of one
of those schools at Rodriguez Elementary
School. Uh I think we had about I think
12 schools that were B's and Fs and
these are the same students, same
teachers and I think just demonstrates
how a change in the assessment can have
a profound impact on school districts.
Uh and so from that point um they've
been uh working really hard and in 24
achieved a B and then slip slid back
just a hair um in 2025 to a D. But we
are confident based on what we're seeing
um in the leadership and the work there
that they will uh be right back on
track. Uh and this is a unique
opportunity to have all students go
together. We have the space um and and
we feel um you know good about kind of
making the adjustment of having all the
students go together uh to um Rodriguez.
There have been questions that I've
received around you know could we
restarted as opposed to to moving them.
Uh certainly that that could be an
option for really any of these. Uh the
question becomes however you know are
you ultimately reducing the number of
seats in Austin ISD which will help um
reduce our cost which then allows us to
use those resources elsewhere. And the
reality is that in this part of Austin
we have a surplus of elementary school
seats. Uh which is why kind of those two
things coming together, turnaround plans
and the um excess seats and the fact
that we have modernized facilities in
areas around um made this the the
recommended um uh turnaround plan
strategy.
All right, so I'm going to shift now. I
know I've said a lot but I want to shift
now to restarts and and kind of talk
about what this will look like for for
Austin ISD. Uh we'll first start with
Linder. Uh so Linder uh it's a larger
student population so the ones
previously were smaller so they could um
easily move to another school. Uh Linder
is very large um 626 students. Uh they
are going through a modernization. It's
it's well underway. If you drive by
you'll see kind of all the great work.
uh and we have academic growth that
shows um that they are moving in the
right direction and we're very confident
that they'll um get a a pause or even
break accountability chain um before the
actual action of the restart occurs. Um,
so we feel good about the restart here.
And again, anytime you can, you know,
have a student population stay in their
neighborhood, um, take advantage of an
investment from the community by way of
the 2022 bond program, uh, and also it
aligns with the trajectory of their
growth. Um, we want to we want to, uh,
kind of deploy that strategy and that's
what we're doing at Linder Elementary
School.
Um, but I also want to be really clear,
we are still, um, adding, uh, resources.
So other instructional coaches are
modifying the student teacher ratio. Um
so just because it's a restart doesn't
mean that they're not going to get
additional resources to ensure success.
Um but uh it is important that we call
them out and and talk about what that
could look like here. Uh we have
different programs at Linder. Um as we
move forward with the new building,
we'll have different spaces that we can
use. Uh and again this is also one of
the schools that has taken advantage um
in participating in the lighthouse and
lab and learning lab uh model which
again has already demonstrated um a
tremendous amount of success in early
literacy. Uh and we're we're really
excited about expanding that. Um and
this is part of that work. As you move
to Linder Elementary School, uh smaller
student population at 340. Uh you can
see here the 2022 accountability of 2023
from a B to an F, an 84 to a 48. and
then the succession of Fs afterwards.
Sanchez was modernized in 2017. Uh this
is one of those um uh schools that has
been talked about um for a little while
now as we've been having conversations
with the community about ways we can
improve our turnaround plans. And uh
we've made some adjustments and what
those adjustments include is is a
restart um at Satcha as opposed to a
reassignment to another school. uh which
means that the students who the school
was it was built for in the neighborhood
um are prioritized and are not uh
required to move to a different campus.
And so you'll see here kind of the the
way that the enrollment structure will
work. First, it'll be currently zoned
Sanchez students and then it'll be
students um from Becker Elementary
School who would like to participate in
the um district-wide dual language
program
and then uh next will be students from
Richtop Riley and Sensit Valley and then
uh lastly any other student who want to
access the program. And so one of the
this is one of those schools that um was
really uh kind of supported by um this
overall goal of moving our wall to 12
language programs where we had higher
number of emerging bilingual students to
ensure that the programs are sustainable
um for years to come. You know the state
of Texas has now changed uh their laws
to require all school districts to have
licensed educators in their classrooms.
just as a as a for context purposes, um
after the pandemic, uh there were lots
of educators that came into the
workforce that were on alternative
certifications um or um and and maybe
didn't complete or moved out and some of
uh and and that kind of continued and
persisted. And so now with the law
changing, we have to ensure that every
student has a licensed educator uh in
front of them. And what makes this a
little more complicated is uh emerging
bilingual students must be served by an
educator uh who is a dual language
certified teacher and we know that those
um those certifications those educators
are in high demand and uh we do not um
have as many as we need. We're always
wanting to invite more into the Austin
ISD family. But um with that law
changing, what that means is we don't
relocate the programs, we'll be at a
point where I have to pull um educators
with that um certification from schools
that have dual language programs but
don't have the appropriate number of
merch valable students to support the
educator. And so we're really trying to
position these programs to be successful
long term uh and not create that
disruption uh downstream. And so this is
a a a plan that kind of addresses those
two things. The programmatic move for D
language as well as a surplus of seats
um east of I35 and north of the river as
well as a turnaround plan um for
Sanchez.
Next is Prett Middle School uh in
souththeast Austin. Enrollment a little
under 600 students. Uh you can see here
um the the progress has been made from
23 to 25 going from 4750 to 59. Prettas
will be receiving students from
Betachchuk but given the trajectory uh
and growth that we're seeing and the
changes we've made this year I feel very
confident that Pas will um pause if not
break the accountability chain this
year. Um and we've been making changes
over the course of the year anticipating
uh that this may be one of the
strategies that's deployed um for this
area.
Uh again here just want to call out some
of the um other uh supports that we're
going to provide um not not being um too
prescriptive in the allocation of
resources um by staff just because it
will be different for every campus. uh a
middle school plan may require more
instructional coaches or maybe even a
assistant principal or a graduation
coach as an example while other uh
turnaround plans require a different
complement of staff. So we really wanted
to [clears throat] create some space to
go and and do that work with our our
principal uh and ensure that it's the
the right the right um person for the
work for that specific campus. Uh here
we are going to be um working to expand
our program in communities and schools
and ACE after school programming after
school program. Uh and we're going to be
working with our uh community uh and
with our uh community engagement team to
ensure that the uh lived experiences of
our families and community and the
knowledge that they have really informs,
you know, how we support our students.
Uh and that'll be leveraging the dual
capacity framework um which has been
talked about uh and and certainly a part
of our overall um objective as a school
district to really lean into that
knowledge that our community has.
Pan Springs
uh smaller enrollment. This is uh you
know one of the schools where a shift of
of just a couple students can really
have an impact on um accountability. Uh
you can see here the ratings will last
three years. Um and uh we are uh
recommending a restart.
Uh a restart in this case will be
district managed restart where we will
um allocate the the side pins just as we
would um in other restarts. Uh and and
really um make sure that we um kind of
balance uh staff who meet the criteria
uh in the turnaround plan staffing
guidelines. um but also
uh make also ensure that we have
familiar faces that are welcoming our
students. And so when we talk about the
staffing guidelines, I want to be really
clear that those pertain primarily to
administrative staff as well as uh those
educators that are in the core
instructional areas. And so for fine
arts or athletics or teacher assistants
or many of the other staff on these
campuses, um you know, they they're not
subject to that requirement. uh and that
includes food service workers and and um
custodial staff. So when we do this, we
we want to be really balanced in our
approach. We want to make sure that we
are um being responsive to the criteria
but also creating a welcoming um
community um for our for our students.
[clears throat] Next is uh another
school that had a B in 2022 and then a
an F in 2023. just demonstrating again
uh kind of how the change in the summit
of assessment of the SAR test uh really
um impacted accountability. And so since
then, WRER has been working really
really hard going from 46 58 to 59. Uh
and that growth uh is is really
encouraging. Uh and we feel very
confident that they will pause um
accountability chain and continue on and
ultimately break their accountability
chain. Waldridge will be receiving
students from Bington.
uh not as a a huge amount um but um
because it's a restart um we're able to
kind of incorporate all the students
into this turnaround plan and it's also
important to note that Waldridge will be
modernized as part of the 2022 bond
program. Uh and so that that really
allows us to to do the work uh and
ensure that our students um receive the
benefit of that community investment um
and uh and we take the next step
together. And so uh here we have noticed
some additional concerns around chronic
absenteeism certainly high mobility
rates and so the plans will be very
responsive to those. Uh and and the one
thing we're also going to reinforce is
just uh our partnership with communities
and schools [clears throat] is making
sure that everybody uh all of our
students and families are connected to
the school uh and and ensuring that our
families are understanding of where
their student is in their academic
journey. So this is one um where uh with
the schools in the area, the
availability of um you know the
strategies that we have to deploy and
the fact that Wilder is being
modernized. Uh we feel like this is a a
strong solution um and very responsive
to the turnaround plan requirements.
So uh the last section here we'll talk
about uh the other campuses that have
two UAS. Uh so again you know you you
start building your turnaround plans
once you get your second uh UA you
typically will take a year to plan and
develop and then three four year three
four and five you you you implement in
order to ensure that you break the
accountability chain and so uh we are um
really leaning into school improvement
uh and those campuses that have two UAS
include TA Brown Valley Hart Houston
Jordan Norman Sims Overton uh Bedron
Pickle Wooten Bertha Satleamine and then
East Side Early College High School. And
so these strategies will be a little be
a little bit different. Uh many of them
align with all the work that we're
already doing. Uh there's been lots of
changes in Austin ISD over the last two
years, improve systems, and so uh we
expect these schools, many of them are
59s currently uh to pause or break the
accountability chain. Um they're
incredible work. We've got great
leaders. We do understand that there'll
be additional investments um at these
campuses. uh but it just won't be to the
same degree uh that are needed at the
other um three UA um campuses or
restarts or or reassignments. Um so we
are um very uh encouraged by the work
that we've seen and the growth that
we've seen uh and and I feel confident
that the um school improvement model is
appropriate for the 2UA campuses
especially when you look at the
stability that we've seen um across them
and the growth that we've seen.
uh dive a little bit deeper into Pickle
because it it does kind of tie back to
uh the work that we're doing around um
dual language and the district-wide um
uh campuses. And so I wanted to just
kind of talk about how the pickle um tap
is responsive to what we heard in the
community, but also is still creating a
a real opportunity for um families um
elsewhere in the district to access uh
that program. And so we'll be be
providing additional resources, but the
pickle students uh will no longer have
to move to a different campus. Again,
the first plan October 3rd and the 31st
uh we had students being reassigned to
HART. That would no longer be the case.
Uh what'll happen here is the um the
first priority of students is going to
be those students who are in the
attendance boundary. Uh so pickle
students. The next will be uh richtop
students um who are who want to um
participate in the program. And then the
next uh group of students would be those
from Becker, Riley, and Sessa Valley
that choose to participate in the
program since there's movement at their
home campus and their home program. And
then lastly, any other students. And
this is really, I think, a good balance
of um being responsive to what the
community has shared with us regarding
um having these schools uh you know um
be and continue to be um strong uh you
know um schools with neighborhood
representation. And so this allows us to
do that and also at the same time not
have to reassign school students from
pickle to another school. Given the size
of um pickle, we have the ability to um
support um this type of plan and we're
excited to do so.
Uh Wooten is um is not too dissimilar.
Uh you know, Wooten is receiving um many
of the students from uh Riley's program,
but Riley is going to be retained as a
neighborhood school. And so when you
think about the size of the school and
again Wooten will be modernized as part
of the 2022 bond program um we're able
to again here ensure that the zone
students at Wooten um have priority and
then uh any students from Riley who
participate in that program will have
next priority and then third will be any
other um wall to wallage program that is
being disrupted and then lastly any
other student uh student group uh that
any other students that want to
participate in the program very similar.
Um we are allocating additional
resources, $385,000 budgeted, um we feel
confident um kind of given the restart
with a new program at this campus while
still uh retaining um the neighborhood
students puts us in a really good
position to have that balance in the
program, but also creates enough space
for students who want to um participate
in that program to access it. And and
that's really been one of the overall
objectives. uh as we move forward. Uh at
the end of the day, we are adding more
seats into these programs. Uh but now
we're able to do it in a way that
doesn't overly disrupt the neighborhood
school that is welcoming the program. Um
and so it is a slight adjustment, but
it's based on what we heard from our
community, we heard from our board, uh
and I think is responsive to to just the
feedback that we've gotten over the last
um many weeks.
So, as we move forward, uh we have um a
upcoming hearing on November 20th. Uh
and then Thursday night, we'll we'll
vote on on the taps. Uh and then, uh
that night and into the early morning,
we'll be submitting our turnaround
plans. Uh and we have many of them to
submit. Um we've been posting them uh
online and we'll be releasing updated
versions. I want to be really clear with
our community. You know, what we submit
to TEA is not all that we're doing.
There are so many other things that we
build into our plans uh that we um
expect of ourselves to ensure our
students are are successful uh but
aren't necessarily required and and
really in some case don't even fit into
the template. So um we're committed to
refining and improving um and continuing
on. Uh I feel very strongly that these
turnaround plans um do are responsive to
community voice. uh also put us in a
good position to um break the
accountability chains but most
importantly allocate the resources to
ensure our students are successful. Uh
and so um with that um I thank you for
the time and I hope you have a great
weekend and we'll be um connecting
shortly with more information.